[Music]
if you or someone you know has been
diagnosed with high cholesterol it's
important to understand what cholesterol
is and why it's important to keep it
under control
cholesterol is a fat like substance made
by your liver and also comes from foods
you intake that is then packaged into
particles called lipoproteins your body
needs cholesterol to make hormones
vitamin D
and a substance that helps you digest
food called bile
this video discusses two types of lipo
proteins that carry cholesterol
low-density lipoprotein or LDL
cholesterol also known as bad
cholesterol and high-density lipoprotein
or HDL cholesterol also known as good
cholesterol
LDL travels through your bloodstream
delivering cholesterol to the cells that
need it
if your body has too much LDL it can
build up in the walls of your arteries
LDL and other substances in your artery
wall form a fatty deposit called plaque
over time plaque can narrow the artery
and reduce blood flow LDL carries
cholesterol into the plaque this is why
LDL is called the bad cholesterol a
common place this plaque can build up is
in your coronary arteries which are the
blood vessels that feed your heart this
plaque buildup causes coronary artery
disease and increases your risk of a
heart attack plaque buildup in other
arteries such as the carotid arteries in
your neck can reduce blood flow to your
brain and increase the risk of a stroke
your liver also makes high-density
lipoprotein or HDL also known as the
good cholesterol
HDL helps remove excess cholesterol from
your cells tissues and from plaque in
your blood vessels this is why HDL is
called the good cholesterol
HDL returns the excess cholesterol to
your liver which removes it from your
body
if after viewing this information you
have questions about cholesterol
or any medications you've been
prescribed to help manage your high
cholesterol speak with your health care
provider it is important to take your
medications as directed by your provider
and report any side-effects you
experience
you